fresh back from their bye week taking on
the Atlanta Falcons this weekís latavius
Murray back on the Rich Eisen show how
you been latavius how you doing I am
doing great so let's get into this
first things first year when you took
the rock for the Saints and Teddy
Bridgewater was he in any way shape or
form somebody that inspired you knowing
his story obviously as well as you do
and having a front row seat and the way
that he handled his business with Drew
Brees out latavius I think you just look
around the league throughout the years
just have guys had to you know deal with
some form of adversity and have known
Teddy Powell for some years and in with
him in Minnesota and now here for him to
really I had the opportunity to come in
and and take over that role and start
and Excel in it I think it was pretty uh
pretty cool to see to be honest well I
mean and just one more on him I'm just
trying to piece together were you there
that the day in practice where his knee
gave where were you still on the Raiders
that day okay so then you just know what
Teddy's been through and what he's gone
through and what he was able to do for
your team I'm wondering how the team
rallied around him when that happened I
think he did a good job of you know
showing Teddy like hey you're a team we
supports and we believe in you and I
think Teddy did a good job of you know
showing everyone what he's capable of
doing I think like I said you know these
kind of things happened obviously it it
was blown blowing up a bit because of
Drew and that position but a lot of
people forgot that Teddy hasn't been a
starting quarterback in this league of
houbolt quarterback at that so we knew
what we had in them he was able to show
that and obviously you've been a
starting running back in this league and
then obviously you you come to New
Orleans and there's camara with you in
the in the
the running back room and then atop the
depth chart what did it mean to you for
you to perform the way that you did when
you had the opportunity to start for the
steam latavius you know when you come to
a new team I kind of felt like you know
when I was in Minnesota being a new guy
I had an injury to come overcome and
it's kind of hard to earn the trust of a
team and to gain the confidence I've
ever wondered if you're not you know you
know Roger make plays but I think I had
done an awful no season and turning cam
but to give the opportunity to respect
everybody so that they know that I'm
somebody that uh you know that they can
count on for sure the Tabas Murray here
on the Rich Eisen sure you also caught
your first ever receiving touchdown as a
professional is that true a lot of
people don't believe it but yeah I just
never had never had no I think I never
thought myself at the be honest but I
didn't know that was a stat that was
kind of hanging out over my head for a
while well where's the ball right now
that's you know I think drew got it I
think he has a game ball if I can get it
from he's got a few of them I mean sure
you got yeah I'm sure he can sacrifice
one you know I understand there there is
no high-end drew or Brees maybe you'll
be a team player so that was did you
have one at UCF I mean I'm wondering if
the high school was the last time you
had one yeah no you ucf ahead I think I
had a few maybe like to it three or four
you know a handful high school I'm
pretty sure I had some munoz but it was
more so just being here and getting
those kind of opportunities I think
that's been a difference being utilized
being able to do
or at that position what is it like
being coached by Sean Payton latavius
walk me through that process yeah I
think like I said I think you know so a
lot of people has asked like you know am
I am I asked to and am I doing something
different or you know are they doing
anything different and I just think
coach Payton has gave me an opportunity
to do everything that a running back
does everything that you know Alvin has
shown to do when Mark but just dial
those plays up for me
as opposed to just saying hey let's get
a smaller shorter bag you know speedy
back in there do those kind of things
he's opened up the playbook to me to
give me opportunity to make plays in
every fashion you know that's been fun
because again I've been able to show a
little bit more of the piano can be
complete back latavius Murray the first
Saints player to have 150 and more
scrimmage yards in two or more scrimmage
touchdowns in straight games since Deuce
McAllister got loose in that manner back
in that 2003 right here on the Rich
Eisen show this is your first week
however with the Saints with Atlanta on
the docket as cam Jordan explained to
you Oh what this means is he used the
word hate week had gone as under way
there in New Orleans yeah so you know I
know all about division games being in
Oakland you know when you have to play
Kansas City Minnesota you know Green Bay
you know I know what the vision games
are about and for any any team I've ever
been on
the most important goal first is when in
the division and in Atlanta says in a
way that sure so as uh because again cam
cam has been very vocal already I mean
it's been about 20 hours essentially
since it's begun
so you basically don't need anybody to
describe to you what this actually means
is what you're saying I know what time
it is and I know what that means and
again I know I know how important it is
and I know the history of these two
teams and this being a really really you
know physical mejora game over
year so I look forward to it it's what
it's all about anybody talking Superbowl
openly there no no no look we we know
what our goals are we know what we want
to go there's no secret to that but I
think I really truly believe that
everybody in this dis locker room as you
know has taken care of the business week
by week again with you know we know what
we want in front of us but I think we've
been a-been understanding that we still
got a ways to get there we still got a
lot we can be better at but for us to
keep finding ways to win you know that's
what it's all about it's going brace
Annette if I had told you the Minnesota
miracle day where you were on the
winning end that one day you'd be in the
New Orleans locker room is a saint what
would you have said to that latavius
Murray I'm not sure but I know you know
when when that play gets brought up on
this I'm kind of a kid his back and
leans back in his chair you know didn't
just have to disappear but we were able
to joke about it I think just a similar
to you know they've they've had a
similar situation last year so it's just
again I think they've made fun made
light of it just kind of been focused on
you know the season and upcoming games
does it come up latavius does it come up
a lot but if we're watching film or
something a minute you know it's
Minnesota happens to come up with theirs
plays that guys remember running first
you know Minnesota did you'd be
surprised here and there the ways that
it can come up I'm like okay but it's
not but it's not you know on purpose
it's just like I said it just happened
to pop up the game but not the moment
but we know when the game gets brought
up obviously we all know how it ended
yes we do a couple more minutes left
here with latavius Murray Saints running
back you went back to school this
weekend correct on your
wait you went back to us yeah yeah we
saw from Johnny Dawkins is social media
feed the basketball coach of shot with
you in them
yeah what was who'd you see back there
walk me through your your week there Tom
well I'm here with a me and trade
Kiwanis Marilyn came after receiver um
when I left was a part of that quote
unquote national championship team a UCF
nice um so some you know something
former alone being there in town
obviously seeing some of the players my
sister attends UCF now so and that's
home and so anytime I get to go back
mana so it's a special place to meet
knowing everything that you know we had
you know do and for it to you know still
be climbing in that direction that I I
intended it hope it would go when I
decided to go there it's a good feeling
for any alumni that comes back and see
it yeah you you were part of the
building blocks for that right no no
don't everybody who at least for me when
I made the decision go to UCF it was
about you know part of history and again
just everything they're doing now that's
what you look you know you hope that was
happening you hope that you were doing
something about that and and I so didn't
saying that I did well latavius thanks
for the call really appreciate it
enjoy if you will hate week which I
don't usually say to a lot of people but
I always I always enjoy our our time
when when you when you come on the show
so I appreciate that apreciation man
right back at you right back engine
you bet that's latavius Murray at
latavius M on twitter and at latavius
Murray on Instagram for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app